I just joining, just gonna listen in.
Hello, sure.
Thank you.
And.
Hi, Marco.
Hey, Ayra, how are you?
I'm doing good. How about you? Are you okay? How's your day?
Yeah, and.
Is that?
How's your week going?
Crazy. It has been non-stop. So, you know, I got a lot of stuff going on trying to get the last set of reviews done for like the people who need to have the reviews. Then I have Jane and two new people that I'm...
Talking to next week likely, um, but it's just it just has been crazy.
Well, silver lining is that it's Friday tomorrow. Hopefully you can finish that before the weekend, right? Okay, I'll make this quick for you, Marco. But then I have Justin here. Have you met Justin already?
Lee.
Yep.
Yeah.
Tina.
I believe you have it, Marco. So I'm part of Natalie's team, actually, from the CX. So I'm going to be your customer success manager. I'm just going to be chiming in here, not going to be talking at all, just going to be listening to the service call. So nice to meet you, Marco.
Oh, okay.
Nice to meet you too. And I mean, again, if I see the face, I may recognize. So it's just one of sometimes just the names, I don't fully know them.
Ohh, sorry.
I.
No worries.
Yeah, I'll just turn off my mic here, but yeah, good to meet you, Marco.
Yep, nice to meet you too.
Okay.
All right, shall we proceed? I will quickly share my screen and then let me know once you guys can see it.
Not yet.
Still going, it's on the way.
How about now?
Yep, we can see now.
Fantastic. So yeah, once again, thank you, Marco, Justin, for joining our biweekly service call. This time, we're going to be reviewing 2 weeks. That's from May 11th to 22nd. Moving on to the agenda items, there's no changes on this. It's all the same.
For check-in, Marco, this is for you. Can you quickly share how are things at this moment with you and Jane and the rest of the team?
No, things are going okay. Definitely continue to make progress. Her numbers in terms of number of calls and ticket triage is pretty healthy. So yeah, no, things so far are going okay.
Wonderful. It's nice to hear that we all have good news for this account. But then I want to assure you that whenever you need help, especially for change performance, you can always reach out to us, okay?
Okay.
All right, moving on to the highlights, Mark, I have two for you. So for the period of May 11th to 22nd, Jane maintained 100% attendance, so there's no absence in tardiness for that 10 working days. And then the last one on the performance side, Jane consistently met the daily call handling expectations.
patients, which I will show you on the following slides.
Mhm.
For the action tracker, I have to. That's all for me. Jane's attendance report, I was able to send that to you and I hope you don't or you don't have any issues with that or do you have questions?
No.
Okay, but yeah, there's no tardiness and no sick leaves and vacation leaves for the last month and a quarter. And then for the second item here, Marco, I will be doing the weekly board review as what we have discussed last service call.
Right.
Mmh.
So I haven't started it yet because last Monday you were out, your company are on a holiday off, so I'll start next week. So probably, and then hopefully I can show you the chart for the KPIs for Jane.
Yeah.
Yep.
And then for, yes, thank you, for the performance analysis slide, these are the KPIs that I'm going to report to you once I have the data. And that will happen once I start doing board reviews.
Okay, perfect.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this is the trend, the utilization trend that I was able to gather based on the Excel file that Jane shared to me. So that Excel file, it contains all the inbound, outbound calls, all the tickets that she's been supporting. So right now she's doing it
manually, but then moving forward, once we start the board reviews, we will automate that. I'll do that for drain.
Yeah.
And then for this chart, for that two weeks data, the total inbound calls, we close it at 105 plus the 66 outbound calls. So overall, the numbers are good. I can see that
We're about to reach the target. But then if we are going to compute it, because you mentioned before that the target that we have would be 250 calls per month, right?
Mhm.
And then in order for Jane to reach the target, she needs to get 11 to 12 tickets per day, which I will help her by our weekly check-in. So I'll make sure to deliver. I'll make sure to update you once we have issues or
And also, I want you to know that I will be removing from this data all of the days that she was out, including holidays, sick leaves, and vacation leaves, okay?
Yeah.
PH.
That makes sense.
Okay, perfect. And also I wanted to add in for triage and dispatch, she's very good helping out the team. So for the two weeks period, she was able to help out with 112 service tickets. Any questions for this slide, Marco?
No.
Okay, thank you for that. And then moving on to the ITBD by design services, you're already aware of this, but since we have Justin on the call, if you have questions with regards to any of these products, you can reach out to him, okay?
OK, sounds good.
Perfect. And for the way forward, Marco, I have two items for you. So for sustaining proactive engagement, Jane, if you, if we're going to check the utilization, she's very utilized. I can see that she's following all the SOPs.
the ITAR guidelines and all of the best practices that your team handed over to her. So I'm very grateful that Jane is helping out your team. So if you have any suggestions for this one or on how we can improve her performance, you can always
Mmh.
Let me know, okay?
OK, we'll do.
And then lastly, for the formal KPI tracking, which I told you earlier, I'll be showing it to you for the next two weeks. That's for our next service call, okay? So we will be doing that, Marco, so that we can gauge the performance and see where we can improve.
Mhm.
Okay.
Okay, sounds good.
Alrighty, perfect. So that's actually the end of my slide, Marco. Do you have any questions for us?
No, no questions.
Okay, and I'll keep you posted, Marco. She should be back tomorrow. I hope her absence doesn't cause any inconvenience on your part. But then let me know if you have any concerns, okay?
Yeah, no, I mean, I understand. She's not feeling well, so it's what it is.
Yeah.
Okay, so I'll stop sharing my screen here. And Michael and, oh, I'm sorry, Justin, do you have anything for us?
All good for me. Thanks, Ayra.
You're welcome. Okay, so once again, thank you, gentlemen, for joining our bi-weekly service call and see you next two weeks. Bye-bye.
All right, thank you. Bye. Thank you, Justin. Bye.
Thanks, Marco. Bye-bye.
Enjoy your day.